همم حبينا اليوم نستضيف الشاب خالد ما
الوراء هذه الاغنيه الموجود معنا في
التاسعه الليله اا مساء الخير مساء النور
انت حضرت مؤخرا اغنيه شامبيونز قبل
اسبوعين مع دي جي روج والغنى طبعا ما يصير
بتحب اغنيه بيروت الاغنيه الشهيره اللي
عملتها
الاغاني اللي بتعملها فعاليات عالميه
يعني
لبيروت
وعلى المونديال يعني
الاغنيه
يعني الجزائر
ههه لم يشارك المنتخب الجزائري ولكن
شاهدنا الكثير من المشجعين الجزائريين
الذين اتوا الى هنا المغرب شوفنا امبارح
وانت كنت في المباراه انا كنت في الملعب
يعني حضرت حضرت
اللقاء مع اسبانيا يعني وكنت يعني وكنا
كنا عصبيين انا شفت شفت الملعب هذه الملعب
كان كله
غريبه يعني ما كنتش ما كنت نتصور يعني
نشوف الحاره قد قديش
المغرب
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يكون عندهم يعني
الفوز وكل المغرب العربي
ان شاء الله تكون عندنا عرس كبير ان شاء
الله اكيد مشاهدين على العربيه
ههه
[ضحك]
الاغنيه اللي هي كلهم فرحانين بهاي
سيلافيي يعني اوفا اوفا
لا لا لا لا لا ان شاء الله
كبيره الله الله ههه
موجود ولكن صوت الشاب خالد دايما موجود في
قلوبنا وعلى همم كل العالم العربي وكل
العالم ايضا يحب الشاب خالد واغانيه
وموسيقى الرائعه جدا اتفضل شاب خالد خليل
سؤال اخير ميسون خليني اسال بس هل سيكون
في ال- في فتحه تكون في المباراه يوم
السبت خالد المباراه التي ستلعب المغرب ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله انا قاعدين نكون هنا ونكون يعني
المغرب
همم
يعني ان شاء الله نكون موجود في الملعب
ونكون كذلك ان شاء الله يكون عندنا فرحه
كبيره ان شاء الله
ههه
طبعا مي يعني في كثير حفلات في كثير يعني
حتى اليوم مساعده المجرد عنده حفل الساعه
9:00 هلا بدات قبل شوي هنا في قطاره وفي
كثير فنانين عندنا احمد شوقي شفت قبل شوي
بالكواليس موجود معنا طبعا الفنان المغربي
راح يكون معنا برده اكيد عنده فعاليات
كثير من الفنانين العرب عندنا كاظم الساهر
جاي قريبا نانسي عجرم همم
مش متذكر هلا مين من الفنانين ولكن هذا ما
يحدث عندنا عندما لا تكون هناك مباريات كل
ما اقترب الوقت من همم النهائي هناك
الكثير من الفعاليات فقط
منتخب المغرب لا لا ما يكون بطل العالم